most movie sequels these days have
something in common they're released
pretty quickly after the previous film
on the franchise
sometimes however it takes a good few
years to get that sequel going and
sometimes it takes decades here are some
of those movies after defeating the
Soviets in 1988 Rambo 3 John Rambo
decided to hang up the old bandana for
two whole decades in fact the Vietnam
vet turned international action hero
wouldn't return until 2008 with the
appropriately titled Rambo the fourth
installment of the First Blood franchise
Rambo fine sliced the loans world-weary
soldier heading into the Burmese jungle
to rescue a group of missionaries of
course after 20 years Rambo's a little
bit slower and a whole lot ring clear so
why did it take so long for Stallone to
get his beloved Green Beret back in
action
well according to Stallone himself he
just couldn't find a story that grabbed
his attention the actor briefly
considered sending Rambo down to Mexico
to rescue a kidnapped girl but
ultimately scrapped that idea and
settled on having Rambo stick up for the
displaced caring people sadly though
absence doesn't always make the heart
grow fonder
and neither audiences nor critics were
really clamoring for a sequel all those
years later currently Rambo is both the
lowest-grossing and worst reviewed film
of the franchise when the original
Independence Day landed in theaters 1996
the alien invasion flick abducted over
800 million dollars at the box office
and it seemed like a sequel should have
been the obvious next step but even
though there was talk of a follow-up as
early as 2002 it took the alien
mothership quite a while to return to
Earth two whole decades in fact
according to director Roland Emmerich
there's a good reason why it took so
long for Independence Day to research
speaking with Entertainment Weekly
Emmerich explained that he's always been
against sequels and would only consider
making one when he can see a way to make
it not look or feel like a sequel never
the last 20 years after the first film
Independence Day flew back into theaters
with the long gestating sequel
resurgence unfortunately the second
movie was missing two major things Will
Smith and an audience the movie was a
flop and the chances are good these evil
extraterrestrials won't be coming back
to earth any time soon
based on the novel by Irvine Welsh
1996's Trainspotting is the pitch black
comedy that first put you and McGregor
and director Danny Boyle on
but the ending left a lot of people
wondering just what happened to
protagonist mark Renton
well literature lovers got their answer
in 2002 when Irvine Welsh brought a
follow-up to his classic novel but film
fans had to wait a little bit longer why
is that original screenwriter John Hodge
did actually tried to adapt Welsh his
second book but the script just didn't
work out as well as that once frequent
collaborators McGregor and Boyle had a
huge falling out after a debacle
surrounding 2000s the beach boy led
MacGregor to believe he would play the
lead in the film but the director picked
Leonardo DiCaprio instead afterward the
two didn't speak for about ten years
which played a huge part in keeping
Trainspotting two away from theatres and
we didn't we didn't speak for a long
time which is such a waste
eventually McGregor and boyle made
amends and soon after there was serious
momentum behind the scenes one week in
2015
boyle and the creative team behind the
first Trainspotting spent some time
brainstorming a way to make the sequel
work and Hodge was finally inspired to
write another screenplay one that picks
parts of Welsh's sequel with a number of
modern elements the result 2017 st2
Trainspotting some people love henry
cavill some prefer Tyler hoechlin but
when it comes time to playing the Man of
Steel nobody does it better than
Christopher Reeve he first on the red
cape in 1978 Superman and came back
three more times to save the world but
Superman three and four weren't classics
to say the least and their failures
killed the franchise for 19 years over
the next couple of decades Hollywood try
desperately to bring the Son of Krypton
back to the silver screen JJ Abrams
wrote a script called Superman fly by
Tim Burton and Nicolas Cage tried to get
Superman lives off the ground and some
people even considered pitting Batman
against Superman along before Zack
Snyder's movie came about finally in
2006 Bryan Singer teamed up with Brandon
Ralph for Superman Returns a movie
that's actually part of the Christopher
Reeve series however singers version
totally ignores the third and fourth
film in the read franchise instead it
picks up after Superman 2 which hit
theaters 26 years prior the singer film
is loaded with references to the Reeve
movies including the voice and image of
the then recently deceased Marlon Brando
as kal-el unfortunately for for Brandon
rouse Superman Returns has largely been
forgotten by fans
at least the guy is still getting a
little work in the world of DC starring
the one and only Jeff Bridges Tron paved
the way for the CG world we live in
today
and sure the visual effects might look a
little dated by today's standards but
today's standards wouldn't even exist
without this 1982 cult classic sadly a
sci-fi movies like The Matrix took CGI
to greater and greater heights it looked
like the world didn't need tron anymore
then in 2007 the folks at Disney decided
to rev up their light cycles and take
Tron out for another spin by hiring
Joseph Kosinski to direct the sequel
hoping to build excitement for the film
and show everybody the look of the world
the filmmakers created a super-expensive
trailer and debuted their short film at
the 2008 comic-con the reaction
encouraged Disney to go ahead with Tron
Legacy the 2011 sequel gave the world to
Jeff Bridges for the price of one not to
mention a pretty cool score from Daft
Punk
unfortunately the 28-year gap between
the film's had dampened audiences
excitement to see another installment in
the franchise resulting in a movie that
didn't exactly light the world on fire
in other words don't expect to see Tron
3 anytime soon in 1979 Mel Gibson
climbed behind the wheel of the v8
interceptor and roared into cinemas with
Mad Max the Australian actor would
reprise the role two more times becoming
the road warrior and finally going
beyond thunderdome of course Gibson
always wrote across the wastelands with
director George Miller the visionary
behind the dusty dirty franchise but
after their 1985 collaboration the
series ran out of gas then in 1998
Miller was minding his own business
literally walking across a road when he
got the idea for a new Mad Max movie the
director wanted to start shooting in
2001 but 9/11 happened wrecking the
economy and screwing up the film's
budget it also didn't help that Mel
Gibson was about to have a major public
meltdown and reveal himself to be well
kind of controversial for years after
Oscar winner Mel Gibson made headlines
for using an anti-semitic statement it
seems that his mouth may have gotten him
in trouble again
so the fourth Mad Max film was put on
hold for a grand total of 30 years until
Miller Tom Hardy and Charlize Theron
finally came together to create the best
film of the entire franchise
fury road and sure it took three decades
to get going but let's be honest it was
more than worth the wait Tom Cruise came
onto the scene with risky
business but it was top gun that made
him the bona fide movie star that he is
today and since everybody knows that Tom
Cruise is a bit of an adrenaline junkie
one who absolutely loves sequels
featuring crazy stunts it seems like a
Top Gun to would have been the most
obvious thing in the world but crews
took a heck of a long time to climb back
into that cockpit true there were rumors
in 2010 that he'd take to the skies once
again but Top Gun director Tony Scott's
tragic suicide in 2012 kept the sequel
from getting clearance for a few more
years however the movie did finally take
off and Top Gun maverick will be soaring
into theaters in 2020 a whopping 34
years after the franchise first took to
the skies here's hoping for more
volleyball more motorcycles and more
highways to the danger zone
it may seem unthinkable now but Blade
Runner was a major bomb when it was
released in 1982 all these decades later
however Ridley Scott's tale of robots on
the run has become one of the most
beloved and influential films in sci-fi
history and to many it was basically an
untouchable movie but there were two
people who thought maybe a Blade Runner
sequel might work but Yorkin and his
wife Cynthia Sykes Yorkin was one of the
producers of the original film and along
with co-producer Jerry Perrine co-owned
the rights to its story for a long time
neither producer wanted to do anything
with the property but once York and in
Psych started thinking about it part two
they brought out fur NCO and got busy
expanding Rick Deckard's world initially
Ridley Scott was going to direct but a
certain other sequel to one of the
directors classics sidelined the English
filmmaker so denis villeneuve a Sicario
and a rival fame was tapped to sit
behind the camera with Arison ford
starring alongside Ryan Gosling Blade
Runner
20:49 hit theaters in 2017 35 years
after the original debut while the movie
wasn't a box-office smash it did impress
critics and the film finally earned the
much deserving and off overlooked Roger
Deakins and Oscar for Best
Cinematography when Mary Poppins was
released in 1964 audiences were eager to
step in time with the film's catchy
songs and the movie earned a staggering
13 Oscar nominations Julie Andrews even
went home with the little gold trophy
for Best Actress and the movie turned
her into a major star while there was
one person who absolutely hated the film
P L Travers the author who first
introduced Poppins to the world Travers
absolutely detested the upbeat
adaptation so what
Walt Disney asked if they could adapt
another one of her eight books about the
prim and proper Poppins Trevor shut
Disney down fair and Dan Disney had
Jeffrey Katzenberg would resume
conversations with Travers throughout
his tenure at the company but the
irascible author made things so
difficult that Katzenberg just gave up
there wasn't any movement on the Mary
Poppins front until Travers passed away
in 1996 about 16 years after her death
the folks at Disney approached the
authors estates again and this time they
actually got to go ahead
sadly Julie Andrews was too old to
reprise the role about 54 years after
the original film Emily Blunt did a
practically perfect job of playing
everybody's favorite flying nanny
directed by Alfred Hitchcock psycho is
arguably one of the finest horror movies
ever made it's the granddaddy of the
slasher genre and gave the world one of
the all-time great villains with Norman
Bates
not to mention making an entire
generation afraid of hotel showers but
this 1960 horror flick wasn't exactly
begging for sequel the original ends
with Norman locked inside a mental
asylum his secrets revealed and his mind
completely gone
but when did a solid conclusion ever
stop anyone from making a sequel the
next installment of the psycho series
first came in book form the original
film was based on a novel by Robert
Bloch and the author followed up his
poem thriller in 1982 with a book that
has elsewhere been described as
unfilmable in fact it's so nuts that
Universal Studios had no desire at all
to adapt blocks new novel instead they
decided to make their own with a
completely different plot they hired Tom
Holland no not that one
to write the script and they were
originally going to make it a TV movie
starring Christopher Walken but then the
og slasher himself Anthony Perkins fell
in love with the script and returned for
the role once Perkins was on board
Universal turned psycho too into a fully
fee a triple film by the time the movie
hit theaters it had been 23 years since
Norman first went off kill-crazy in that
motel bathroom and while it's probably
true that Hitchcock's classic didn't
need sequel psycho to has its fair share
of defenders so it wasn't a total waste
at least check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]